I'm going to show you how to become a
confident person, even if you see
yourself as being naturally shy. And
there's one simple sentence that
completely destroyed the way I thought
about shyness in my 20s, which helped me
transform from shy to someone who's now
spoken on thousands of stages to
millions of people. And once you hear
this sentence, you won't be able to
unhear it. The reason you are so good at
being shy is because you've been
practicing shy behaviors for the last
10, 20, 30 years of your life. In
communication, you become what you
practice. And because you've been
practicing shyness consistently,
of course you're great at it. Now,
here's what this means. Shyness is not a
personality. It's not who you are. It's
just a set of behaviors that you've
practiced so consistently for so long
that they now feel like they're a part
of your identity, but they're not.
Confident people, on the other hand,
they're doing the exact same thing.
They're just doing it in reverse.
They're practicing confident behaviors
consistently, and they've become what
they've been practicing, which means if
you want to be more confident, you don't
need to change your identity and who you
are, you just need to change what you
practice. And think about this. Have you
ever met someone who's Look, I'm going
to be a bit honest here. Someone who's a
bit of a turd. Yeah, you know the type,
the selfish, self-centered, always
interrupting people, always making the
conversation about themselves, never
lets anybody finish a sentence. Yeah,
that person. That person became that way
because they've been practicing those
behaviors their entire life without ever
realizing it, and they don't have any
friends who care about them or love them
enough to tell them the truth that
they're being a turd. And also, because
they've never stopped to examine
themselves, they've got zero
self-awareness, and trust me, I'd much
rather be shy than be a turd. Back to my
point. This video isn't for turds, it's
for those of you who are shy. So, let me
ask you this question right now.
Who are you practicing being every
single day?
That's the question I want you to just
take a moment and think about.
If you're not happy with how you come
across and you're not happy with how
people perceive you, and you're not
happy with the way you perceive yourself
even, then change the things you're
practicing and it will change the person
that you become. You are not stuck.
You're not stuck being shy and yes, even
the kids aren't stuck being kids. If
they practice more compassionate, more
kind, more loving behaviors, they could
become a wonderful person. You too could
become a more confident person, a more
charismatic person, a more authoritative
person, if you practice those behaviors.
Now, before I get into the confident
behaviors, let's first become more aware
of the shy behaviors that are no longer
serving you. You probably can't tell
right now from the way that I'm
speaking, but when I was younger, I was
really, really shy. And I'll be honest,
I was a bit of a kid as well. But
luckily, I practiced that part out of
me.
>> You're still a kid, Vin.
>> So is your face, Peter.
>> What? That doesn't make sense.
>> So is your face. So is your face always
makes sense. This video that I'm about
to share with you is footage of me from
about 16 years ago. I was trying to just
turn on the camera and speak, and as you
watch it, I want you to look for the shy
behaviors. See if you can spot them.
>> Hey, everyone. Um
welcome to
my garage uh office / um home, where I
sleep, everything.
Uh
I just have to make this video. Um
I think I said my name was Vin already.
I'm not sure, but I press record and I'm
just want to see what comes out. But
>> That's enough of that. Did you catch the
shy behaviors? Because once you can name
the shy behaviors, you can actually
start to change and transform them. But
if you didn't catch them and if you
didn't know what to look for, let me
break down specifically what shy
behaviors are. Shy behaviors fall into
three categories. You've got visual,
vocal, and verbal. Let's start with
visual. That's what you do with your
body. And the first thing is poor eye
contact.
When you speak, your eyes are either
looking down, they're darting around
really quickly, or they're avoiding the
other person completely, and you're not
even looking at them. In the world of
communication, eye contact signals
trust. When you avoid it, people
unconsciously read it as nervousness, a
lack of belief in what you're saying,
and low levels of confidence. Now, the
next one is
bad posture.
Here's where your shoulders are rolled
forward, your head is slightly down, and
your body is caved in. Most people don't
realize that your body actually
introduces you before you introduce
yourself. If someone sees you from
across the room with that posture that I
had before, they've already made a
judgment. They will look at you as being
someone who's shy, low status, low
levels of confidence before you've even
said a single word. You've been
categorized without being given a chance
to speak. That's how powerful posture
is. It's the loudest form of body
language. And lastly,
limited
gesture
vocab.
Here's where your hands are generally
clasped to get clasped.
Is it clasped? This is where your hands
are clasped.
Here's where you have your hands in the
prayer position. Your elbows are close
to your sides. You are taking up as
little space as possible. Gestures are
the amplifier for your words. When you
strip them out, everything you say
becomes flatter, it becomes less
convincing. Think about the most
confident speakers you've ever watched.
Their hands are alive. They're moving
with purpose. They're taking up space.
Compared to that, someone who's standing
completely still, arms pinned, prayer
position, they're being as small as
humanly possible. I mean, doesn't this
look like somebody who's shy? The second
category of shy behaviors is vocal.
That's what you do with your voice. And
the first limiting behavior here is
a low default
volume.
What I mean by this is that if you
imagine volume having a scale from zero
to 10, you're speaking at about a three,
and you're staying there as a default.
And then, as an example for you, if I
stay at about a three out of 10, and I
stick to this,
how do you perceive my level of
confidence?
Seems pretty low, doesn't it? Next is
mumbling and poor articulation.
When you do this, people have to work
really hard to understand you. Do you
know who mumbles in life? Babies and
mumble rappers. And do they deserve
respect? Absolutely not. Watch what
happens when I start to
mumble. I'm going to start talking like
this now. I mean, you know how you
perceive my level of confidence.
>> [laughter]
>> It's so bad, isn't it? And the last
thing is monotone
delivery.
That's where you speak at one level, no
variation. A big part of confidence is
aliveness. When you speak in a monotone,
for example, if I spoke like this, how
alive do I sound? I don't sound alive,
do I? A core component of confidence,
once again, is aliveness. So, you've got
to be careful of the monotone delivery.
And the final category of shy behaviors,
verbal.
What you do with your words. This is
where you are
talking in circles, rambling, and
speaking with no clear point.
And more often than not, people who are
really good at being shy tend to not
speak up at all. And sometimes you think
by not saying anything at all, you're
able to avoid judgment, avoid being in
the spotlight, and you think it's a good
thing. But what you don't realize is
that you're also avoiding career growth.
The people who speak up during team
meetings and at work-related events,
they have more visibility. And the more
visibility you have when it comes time
for promotion,
guess who gets picked for the promotion?
Those who are the most visible. Because
if you're invisible, they don't even
consider you. And then guess who gets
the promotion? Bloody Jason, the
He's always speaking up in
team meetings, even when he's got
nothing brilliant to say. But he's the
only one doing it, and as a result of
that, he's the only one that is visible.
And as a result of that visibility that
he has, when it comes time for
promotion, he's the one that gets it.
And you're sitting there going, "Damn
it, it should have been me." So, if
you're sick and tired of Jason, and you
want to learn how to be more visible in
your workplace, and you want to learn
how to turn your thoughts into words
quickly so that you can speak up in a
team meeting, so that you can ask
questions without feeling stupid, then
join me for a free 2-hour masterclass,
where I take you through three powerful
communication frameworks that are going
to allow you to speak up at a moment's
notice while under pressure, and speak
in a way that has high levels of
authority, high levels of clarity,
that's also concise. So, come learn with
me. Click the link description or scan
the QR code on screen. Go check it out.
Now that you're aware of the shy
behaviors, let's learn about the
confident behaviors. And they're
actually relatively simple. It's
literally the opposite of what we just
spoke about. Starting with the visual
behaviors. [clears throat] The first one
is strong, deliberate
eye contact. Next is great posture. And
let me let me get up and show you what I
mean by this specifically.
Great posture is where your feet uh
shoulder width apart, shoulders down and
back, head held nice and high, large
gestures, elbows away from your body,
and you move. You use the space that
you've been given. So, if you're
speaking in a boardroom, use the space
that you have with purpose. And by doing
this, it communicates and radiates
confidence. And the final thing just to
note here is that when you're willing to
take
up more space,
you will appear more confident. I want
you to watch how one of my students
immediately upgrades their perceived
levels of confidence just by taking up
space and using more hand gestures.
Check this out.
>> Hi, I am Pingkan from Jakarta,
Indonesia.
And I would like to take this challenge
from Vince from day one of
Break the Mold. Hello, everybody. My
name is Pingkan, and I'm here to improve
my communication skills. Why do I want
to improve my communication skills? It's
because
I would like to make my world bigger
than it is currently.
>> How much more confident do they look?
All right, on to the next category,
vocal. The first thing is strong volume,
great articulation,
pronunciation,
and lots of melody.
And the thing about confident people is
that they have lots of vocal variety.
Now, I want you to listen to another
student of mine here play with their
volume. One simple change, but watch the
transformation. Check this out.
>> So, if I did improve um my
communication, it will give me
confidence that I can take my career to
the next level. It will give me the
confidence that I can do the things that
I really want to do in life. Reason why
I'm doing this course is so that I can
take my career to the next level. I will
be able to do what I have not yet able
to do until now. People will take me
seriously if I'm able to communicate
those things clearly, articulate my
point, make them so that they learn
what I'm trying to say.
>> Once again, how much more confident did
they sound as they started to practice
these new set of behaviors? It's wild,
right? Verbal, the number one thing that
all confident people do when they're
speaking is they use
frameworks.
They don't just wing what they say, they
follow frameworks, which helps you
structure your thoughts so you can speak
more clearly, concisely, and coherently.
And if you want to learn the three most
powerful frameworks, click the link in
the description or scan the QR code.
Now, I want you to watch how one of my
students uses one of the simple
frameworks they learned from that
training to be able to share their
thoughts in a more concise, coherent,
and clear way.
>> That's often times my problem with
communication as I'm rambling, as you
put it yesterday, is to be more direct,
but also to be more empathetic. Um
typically at work, but also I've got a
wife and and two daughters. So, if
there's one key takeaway for this
course, it's for
uh me to have more control over my
message.
>> Ah, how good is that? Now, I know what
you're thinking. The biggest question at
this point is, "All right, Vin, I get
it. I understand now that shy is not my
identity, shy is just a series of
behaviors, and now that I've identified
that I do a lot of these behaviors, and
I've also identified the behaviors that
I should practice, the confident ones,
then my question to you, Vin, now is how
long does it take for me to change? How
long does it take for me to see the
transformation?"
Well, that's a very long question you
just asked me, but here's what I'm going
to say.
The changes that you saw with my
students in the videos that I've shared,
it took them 3 days. Most people will
wait their entire lives before they
change the way they communicate. Some
actually never do. So, most of them
spend their entire lives living inside
the illusion that they are shy, that
they're stuck with being shy. And then
from that belief, they build a stack of
limits around themselves. Oh, I'm shy,
so I can't ask for a pay rise. I'm shy,
so I can't get that damn promotion.
Jason's probably going to get it. I'm
shy, so I can't advance in my career.
I'm shy, so I can't step into the life
that I actually want. All of these are
myths. They're false beliefs. They're
not real. They're built on a case of
mistaken identity. Shy is just a series
of behaviors, and behaviors can be
changed. So, here's what I want to leave
you with. You are not shy. You've been
practicing shyness. And the most
important question you can ask yourself
right now about your communication
skills, about how you shop, is this. Is
the person that I'm practicing the
person I want to be?
If the answer's no, you know what to do.
Start practicing confident behaviors.
The ones that I shared with you in this
video. Do it consistently. Do it with
intention. And give the future version
of yourself a chance. And this is just
the beginning. As you're practicing new
communication behaviors, you're going to
make some common mistakes that can be
avoided. So, make sure you watch this
video up here to learn what they are.
These are simple things you can adjust
to help you level up your confidence
even more. See you in the next video.